day 1 of the second leg of the  Grantchester employment belgium the best  chess players in the world will to start  the event with a bang as they cross  swords in three exciting games of rapid  newcomer gang watching sword to an early  lead with two wins in a row for the loss  of this one about high and round three  he brought him back to earth at the end  of the day in a tie for second i cleaned  by sheer madras made the miracle game  against writing they're coming to finish  the day near the top of the standings  for the score of the round with branch  escort champ what we throw this beyond  overly ambitious magnus crossing the  brat sole possession of first outfit is  for another day of throwing battles they  devise some sort of and start right